مساء الخير اذا كنت لا تؤمن بما قاله
وينستن تشيرش الزعيم البريطاني الشهير بان
في السياسه لا توجد صداقات دائمه ولا
عدوات دائمه فما عليك الا ان تتابع تطورات
الازمه القطريه حتى تتاكد من صدق مقوله
تشيرشل اعداء اليوم هم اصدقاء الامس
واصدقاء الامس هم اعداء اليوم في عمليه
يعني في تغير مستمر في التحالفات وفي
العداوات زي لعبه الكراسي الموسيقيه انا
بقول الكلام ده في محاوله للاجابه على عدد
كبير من الاسئله احنا جالنا
315 تعليق سؤال على حلقتي قطر معظم هذه
الاسئله بيحاول يسال او بيسال على اسباب
ودوافع الاطراف المختلفه من الازمه على
سبيل المثال ليه موقف قطر ليه او ليه
الحكومه القطريه قطريه خدت صف الحكومه
التركيه خدت صف قطر في هذه الازمه الحاده
المساله ببساطه انه او مش ببساطه المساله
بنوع من التبسيط لان في دوافع كتيره ان
الحكومه الحكومه التركيه ليس لها ظهير في
سياساتها القائمه على دعم التيارات
الاسلاميه لاسباب كثيره منها اسباب داخليه
تدعم شعبيه و يعني حزب الحريه والعداله
وشعبيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
فضلا عن انه دعم الطيار الاسلامي احد
ادوات سياسته الخارجيه خصوصا بعد
2011 ليس له من ظهير في هذا الدد الا
قطر وبالتالي هو يشعر ويشعر رجال حزبه انه
اذا تم عزل قطر واجبرها على تغيير
سياساتها سيصبح بلا ظهير وبلا اي حليف
يشاركه بعض وجهات نظره او بعض سياساته فده
شيء مهم بالنسبه للرئيس التركي الامر
الثاني ان الرئيس التركي لا يثق في
المعسكر الاخر اللي بيضم السعوديه وقطر
ومصر والبحرين لاسباب كثيره خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالامارات
ومصر وشرحنا انه لهم موقف شديد العداء
والضغينه تجاه جماعه الاخ اخوان المسلمين
التي ينتمي اليها او ينتمي اليها على
الاقل بحكم التعاطف لكن كمان كان في سبب
اخر في الدوائر يعني او الاعلام التركي في
قناعه بان الامارات لعبت دورا
مهما في دعم الجماعات التي رتبت الانقلاب
على الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
يوليو الماضي وسواء صح هذا الكلام ام لم
يصح فكانت الامارات وقطعا مصر و كثير من
الدول الاخرى التي باستثناء قطر اللي هي
كانت اول دوله اميرها يسارع بالاتصال ب في
ليله الانقلاب للاطمئنان عليه ثم تهنئته
بانتهاء الانقلاب او هذا الكابوس بالنسبه
لرجب طيب اردوغان يرغب في انه يستغل هذه
الفرصه للنيل لافشال محاولات الامارات
ومصر من ترقيع قطر ده جزء من القصه لكن
كمان في جزء منه الاسباب التجاريه اللي
يامل رجب طيب اردوغان وهو رجل نهاز للفرص
وهذا امر لا يعيبه في انه يستغل هذه
الفرصه بانه يوسع من صفقات قطر معاه
وبالتالي يعمل بحبوحه في اقتصاده وكمان هو
مستند على انه حتى لو كان في عقاب سعودي
لن يطول كثيرا لانه انبنب بارت يعني يعني
جزء اساسي او يعني شريك اند سبنس بل لا
يمكن الاستغناء عنه على المدى البعيد
بالنسبه
لسعوديه وحلفائها ده بالنسبه للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان او الموقف التركي وبالمناسبه
كل ما يقال عن ارسال قوات تركيه الى قطر
وانه هذه القوات سوف تعتمد عليها قطر في
رضع اي محاولات عدوان خارجي عليها وانه
يعني انه الرئيس الرجب طيب اردوغان امهل
الاطراف حتى ح بعد العيد ليس الا يعني
زوبعه في فنجان لانه لا يوجد اي من
الاطراف في الوقت الحالي يفكر في استخدام
القوه العسكريه واذا حدث لا قدر الله
استخدام للقوه العسكريه فصاحب اليد العليا
واليد الطوله في هذا الامر سوف تكون
الولايات المتحده التي يوجد على ارض قطر
11000 من قوتها الموجوده هناك وعلى بعد
مسافات مساف مفه قريبه جدا من مركز
الاسطول الخامس موجود في البحرين وبتالي
لا يمكن لا يمكن ان يتصور احد ان تركيا
يمكن ان تنافس او ان تتخذ موقفا لا ترغب
فييه الولايات المتحده اللي لا قدر الله
لو حدث وهذا امر مستبعد سوف تكون هي من
تحدد شكل التدخل واطرافه وتحسم نتائجه ده
فيما يتعلق بالموقف التركي
اما فيما يتعلق بالموقف الايراني فليس
صعبا ان نفهمه ربما يكون خصوصا بالنسبه
للخليجيين او الشخص المتابع بالنسبه لغير
الخليجيين والناس اللي هم زي الناس في مصر
او دول المغرب العربي او حتى من خارج
المنطقه مش بالضروره او مش كلهم بيعرفوا
انه قطر
وايران بيشارك في اكبر حقل للغاز في
العالم اللي هو حقل غاز الشمال
اللي الايرانيين بيسموه بارس الجنوبي او
يعني اسمه بالفارسي اللي تلتيه في المياه
القطريه وتلته في المياه الايرانيه
وبالتالي اهم مصدر للثروه القطريه واللي
اللي اتبنت عليها كل اسباب ونفوس الدوله
القطريه في العالم بتتشكل فيه مع ايران
وبالتالي رغبتها في الا تغضب ايران وان
تحتفظ معها بعلاقات جيده امر مفهوم وده
هنتكلم عليه في وقت لاحق ومش غريب انه
ايران وقطر اللي احيانا بتتقاس مصالحهم في
سوريا واللي تقاطعت مصالحهم في سوريا
وتقاطعت نظريا في اليمن انه قطر طوال
الوقت بتحاول انها تلعب على الحبلين وهذا
احد اسباب غضب السعوديه الامارات فتحاول
مثلا ان تكون في نفس التحالف الذي يعني
يضرب الحوثيين لكنها تحاول التفاوض مع
الحوثيين تكون في نفس التحالف اللي بيحاول
الايقاع باسقاط النظام حكومه الرئيس بشار
الاسد في سوريا لكن في نفس الوقت تحاول ان
تحتفظ بعلاقات طيبه مع حزب الله ومع ايران
اللي هي و اللي بتقف في الصف الاخر فدي
مساله محيره ومساله احيانا بتتجاوز قدره
الاطراف الاخرى على التسامح والاحتمال ليه
قطر بتعمل كده دي مساله عاوزه حلقه ثانيه
لوحدها لانه مرتبط بفهم التاريخ القطري
ودوافع الاسره الحاكمه في قطر وجهه نظرها
في كيف تحمي امنها القومي واللي ممكن
اقوله في جملتين مؤقتا حتى ناتي اليها
بالتفصيل هذا هو الدرس الذي تعلمته قطر من
تجربه او من ماساه الكويت سنه 90 حين
غزاها صدام حسين وقتها ادرجت قطر انه لم
تستطع لم تستطع اموال الكويت ان تحميها
ولم تستطع الس السعوديه اللي هي الشقيق
الاكبر اللي بيمثل لها يعني عملاق وقوه
كبرى ان هي تمنع هذا الضرر وادركت انه
افضل سياسه لحمايه امنها القومي انها الا
تعتمد على سله واحده وان هي تستثمر في
سلال كثيره احد اهم هذه السلال انها تخلي
نفوذها او بقائها وسلامتها مرتبط بمصالح
دول كبرى كثيره زي الولايات المتحده زي
بريطانيا زي المانيا زي روسيا زي ايران
طبعا ف عددت العلاقات التجاريه وعددت
العلاقات الاقتصاديه مع كل هذه الاطراف
كما استثمرت وبسخاء في التيار الاسلامي
الذي ا يعني رات فيه انه هيكون سند ليها
ووسيله لمد نفوذها ودي قصه نتكلم عليها في
وقت اللاحق حتى لا تتكرر معها ماساه
الكويت سنه
1990 طبعا عوده الى الموقف الايراني انا
بقول ليس صعبا ان نفهم ان
ايران باعتبار ان هي الخصم الاساسي
للسعوديه التي تقود هذا التحالف ضد ضد قطر
هتنتهي هذا الشقاق علشان تحاول ان هي
تستقطب احد اطراف مجلس التعاون مجلس
التعاون
الخليجي في محاوله منها ان هي تنفذ الى
مجلس التعاون الخليجي ب يعني من الناحيه
السياسيه وتدعم احد اهم الدول او احد
الدول الخليجيه وتبقى دخلت الى الخليج من
باب واسع وده هي سعدها
و من نواحي مختلفه منها انها تفتت وحده او
تفتت تماسك الخليج الموجه ضدها فده امر
طبيعي جدا يعني وممكن كمان وده المؤكد
انها تحاول انها تتفاوض مع قطر غير
المنافع التجاريه تتفاوض مع قطر بحيث انه
تكون الساحه تكون يكون قطر اقل دعم
للجماعات المناوئه لايران في في سواء في
العراق او في سوريا فيما يتعلق بالولايات
المتحده احنا شرحنا موقف الولايات المتحده
ومن الواضح جدا ان الولايات المتحده اخذت
موقف التحالف السعودي المصري الاماراتي
البحريني لاسباب كثيره
منها كما قلنا في الحلقه الماضيه انه هي
احد اهم اولويات الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
هو تجفيف منابع التمويل الارهاب ووجد ان
في اجماع من شركاء الخليجيين ان السياسات
القطريه بتمول الجماعات الارهابيه صحيح
انه مش بالضروره تكون الحكومه متورطه بشكل
مباشر لكن بشكل غير مباشر ووجد ان بعض
يعني اقطان السياسه الخارجيه في الولايات
المتحده مسؤولين سابقين وحاليين بييد نفس
الكلام فخد هذا الموقف لاحظوا ان في
اعتبارات
اخرى بتقوي بتشرح لنا ل الرئيس الامريكي
اكثر تشددا مع قطر وليه كبار مسؤوليه زي
وزير الخارجيه ترسن او وزير الدفاع ماتس
واخد موقف اقل تشددا المساله ليها علاقه
بتفاصيل العلاقات وشبكه العلاقات في
واشنطن يعني ركزوا معانا في هذه
العلاقه المستشار الرئيسي في شؤون الشرق
الاوسط والشخص اللي بيثق فييه دونالد وهو
رجل جديد على السياسه هو جارد كشنر زوج
ابنته ومستشاره خصوصا في شؤون الشرق
الاوسط وهو شاب شديد الذكاء ومتعدد
المواهب والقدرات لكنه جديد على السياسه
استاذه واللي بيحتفظ بعلاقه كبيره معاه
وبيث فيه وبتشاور معاه بصوره اسبوعيه ان
لم تكن يوميه هو يوسف بن عتيبه السفير
الاماراتي في واشنطن وهو رجل بالغ النفوذ
في واشنطن ويحظى باهتمام والج الجميع يسمع
له اذا كان جارد كشنر بيسمع الى يوسف بن
عتيبه يبقى هو اقرب الى طبعا الاستماع الى
وجهه نظره الاماراتيه السعوديه في كثير من
الامور وبالتالي جارد كشنر قادر على
التاثير على دونالد ترامب يبقى الحلقه
جايه من هنا يوسف يتحدث مع جارد وجارد
يتحدث مع دونالد ترامب ودونالد ترامب عنده
اعتبارات اخرى زي ما قلت لحضراتكم رؤيته
مصالحه الاكثر مع هذه الدول ادراكه انه في
النهايه لن يخسر قطر تماما لانه يعني من
غير المتصور ان قطر هتقول له تفرض عليه
مغادره الاراضي القطريه فيغادر القاعده
العسكريه من غير المتصور ان قطر يعني لن
ترضخ تماما
ا قطر او غيرها يعني عشان نكون منصفين
لاراده الولايات
المتحده لاحظوا بقى انه في المقابل انه
وزير الخارجيه ووزير الدفاع وزير الخارجيه
كان رئيسه لشركه اكسن موبيل اكبر شركه نفط
في العالم وبيربي علاقات قويه جدا بقطر
بحكم منصبه السابق وكذلك وزير الدفاع اللي
بحكم موقعه مواقعه الكثيره في الجيش
الامريكي كان على علاقه وثيقه بما يعني
بالاجواء القطريه بحكم القاعده العسكريه
الموجوده هناك من سنه
2003 لانه على علاقه بكثير من الاطراف
القطريه والناس النافذين فهم اكثر تعاطفا
مع الحكومه القطريه واقل رغبه في التصعيد
من الرئيس الامريكي هذا لا يعني ان في
النهايه انه هذه الاطراف يعني كل واحد
فيها يعني ليست جمهوريه الموز ولكن
الولايات المتحده دوله كبيره وبيبقى في
قدره لكبار المسؤولين ان يكون لهم ارائهم
الشخصيه وحتى هذه اللحظه الرئيس الامريكي
قادر على انه يحسم الموقف الامريكي انه
اقرب مش اقرب انه في المعسكر السعودي
المصري الاماراتي الى هذه
اللحظه هذا ف ما يتعلق بالموقف الامريكي
انت بتشوف يعني مواقف اخرى تجد مثلا على
سبيل المثال الموقف الالماني من اللحظه
الاولى الموقف الالماني قلق جدا على قطر
ويدعو الاطراف الى فك الحصار و طبعا
الموقف تغير قليلا بعد زياره الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي الى المانيا لكن
ليه المانيا كانت واخده قلخ جدا على
قطر السبب بمنتهى البساطه ان قطر استثمرت
مبالغ ضخمه جدا جدا في كثير من الشركات
والبنوك الالمانيه خصوصا
شركات يعني السيارات وبالتالي اي ولها
علاقات تجاريه مع قطر وبالتالي قطر
المانيا تخشى ان تؤدي هذه العزله والحصار
الاقتصادي ان تتاثر شركاتها سلبا ولذلك هي
كانت قلقه جدا على مصالحها وتريد ان تطمئن
على مصالحها او ان تجد بدائل
اخرى هتجد نفس القصه بالنسبه لبلد زي زي
روسيا اللي هي واقع الامر ان علاقتها
الوحيده بقطر حاجتين منافسه يعني غير
مباشره على سوق الغاز في العالم وان كانت
قطر لا تمثل خطرا عليها كل واحد فيهم
بيتنفس على اسواق مختلفه واستثمارات
القطريه اللي بلغت حوالي 11 مليار دولار
في احد اهم شركات النفط في العالم اللي هي
روز نفت الروسيه العام الماضي لكن روسيا
اللي بدات وكانها ترغب انها تلعب دور
الوسيط تدرك انها لا تصلح وسيطا لان قطر
من سنه لان روسيا من سنه
1917 مع الثوره البلشفيه او الثوره
الشيوعيه الى الان لم تحضى ابدا باي قوه
ناعمه في الخليج الاعتبارات يطول شرحها
معظمها انه الثقافه مختلفه وانه منطقه
الخليج كانت دائما منطقه نفوذ غربي
لبريطانيا والولايات المتحده ولم تكن ابدا
مجالا للنفوذ ال الروسي ده بايجاد شديد
يعني الستيك هولدر الاساسيين اطراف النزاع
الاساسي تبقى اسئله اخرى شديده الاهميه
تحتاج منا الى حاله اخرى احد اهم هذه
الاسئله هل نحن امام تضارب مصالح فقط ام
اننا في معركه اخيار في مقابله اشرار كما
صورها الرئيس الامريكي يعني هل قطر هي
يعني محور الشر في مقابل محور الاخيار ولا
ان السعوديه ومصر والامارات هذه دول شريره
بتحاول ان تخلق طاقه
النور يعني والخير وال الثوريه في الدوله
القطريه واقع الامر ان هذا يعني يحتاج منا
الى اجابه على سؤال اخر مهم جدا من هم
الارهابيون وهل فعلا قطر بتدعم الجماعات
الارهابيه هذان السؤالان ان شاء الله نخصص
لهما حلقه الحلقه القادمه باذن الله
اشكركم والى اللقاء